oui vous l'avez vu Nancy Pelosi a eu
bien du mal à s'asseoir à faire
s'asseoir les membres du Congrès
rassemblés en session extraordinaire qui
ont accueilli le président zellinski
debout et sous un tonnerre
d'applaudissements comme le vieux dôme
du Capitole n'en avait plus vu depuis
bien longtemps le président volody
mirzeninski debout devant tous les
parlementaires des États-Unis dans sa
simple tenue de combat une tenue de
combat que le monde connaît désormais
c'est donc adressé à la représentation
nationale américaine en anglais et à
travers eux au peuple américain chers
américains vous qui chérissez la paix et
la liberté il n'en fallait pas plus
l'Ukraine n'est pas tombé l'Ukraine et
vivante l'Ukraine se bat c'est simple à
chaque fois que le président zellinski a
ponctué une phrase l'assemblée
rassemblée devant la vice-présidente et
Nancy Pelosi c'est levé pour applaudir
cette guerre que nous menons n'est pas
simplement une guerre pour défendre mais
pour survivre
cette guerre définit ce que le monde de
nos enfants sera demain encore une
phrase qui a fait mouche évidemment sur
les parlementaires américains chacun des
mots de volodimeki à toucher le
Parlement américain au cœur sans effort
simplement en racontant l'Ukraine des 10
derniers mois l'Ukraine a tenu contre
tous les pronostics contre toutes les
prédictions il y a 300 jours devant la
brutalité de l'offensive russe le
président Biden avait pourtant proposé
aux jeunes présidents de l'évacuer sa
réponse avait sidéré le monde on s'en
souvient je n'ai pas besoin d'un taxi
mais de cartouches pour me battre
l'histoire écrite par les ukrainiens et
par leur président démontre que ce
n'était pas une formule voilà dis-moi
que la petite armée de ce très jeune
pays tient la Russie tout entière en
échec moins de 24 heures avant de se
présenter devant l'ensemble des
parlementaires de la démocratie la plus
puissante de la planète vol Audi
mirzelinski était dans une tranchée il
l'a raconté à ses parlementaires de
l'Est avec des hommes qui auront
peut-être perdu la vie demain alors le
président ukrainien est tout simplement
venu demander à son principal allié de
tenir autant que son armée tient il
n'est pas venu demander aux Américains
de mourir les Ukrainiens s'en chargent
Matthieu